والله كبست كبس و مزاريب عننا ج من در
بكر مزع الخيم كلها حتى تعال شوف كيف
الخرق الكبير مزل نزل علينا وفيش بلاز
البسها 100 سقعه كمان فش عندي سويتر حتى
كمان اخته 40 40 يوم ميت من السقعه ها
اخوي اطلع
كيف
ما عندش
شبشب امبارح الشطاء ادت علينا واحنا تسعه
انفار والحرامات
ثلاث احرامات في الشبشب عشان
نمشي والشبشب حقه 80
شيكل كنا في بيتنا ما تدخلش ولا نقطه ميه
علينا وكنا نكيف في الشتاء وكنا نلعب كنا
ما يصير فينا شي بس هنا هنا وضعنا زي
الزفت ولا لعب دف منقع انا واخوي واختي
وابوي وامي على حرام فرشه واحده فرشين
بفردها بطول وبنام يعني مهما كان الظروف
صعبه الا انه ولا شي بغني عن دفع البيت
وعن راحه البيت اما هي الحرب علمتنا حاجات
كثيره علمتنا خلت الفقير خلت الغني فقير
حس كل واحد ظروف الفقير وظروف الفيضانات
وحسنا بكل شيء بالحياه
صعب مش زي الشتا اللي احنا كنا فيه
ببيوتنا وبطل في عننا اواعي نلبس وبطل في
شيء وكنا في كل مكان بنغرق وسانت كلهم ميه
وطحنا كله ميه خرب كلنا غرقنا وفرشنا ب
نشرهم كيف بدنا نشرهم س
تشت اليوم الدنيا ساقه وحنا ما عننا اواعي
نلبس ونحنا باقينا وحنا صغار نحب الشتاء
احنا عشان الدنيا حرب بنحبش الشتاء نحن
الحين صق عنينه منن واعي مشان الله ليش
نحن هيك بدارنا فينا احنا مننا واعي بدنا
نتدفى زي الناس
مدفين اجواء سيئه كثير بنعيش برد وكنا
يعني نحب الشتاء كثير الحين صرنا نكره
الشتاء يعني ايش يعني حرام حرامين نتغطى
كنا في الدار نتغطى ث احرامات نشرب سحلب
نشرب اشياء دافيه هالحين صرنا نرشح ونعي
وننزل على الس فيش ملابس فيش ملابس اصلا
وضع ماساوي للغايه طول
صاحي مش عارف انام سقعه مش عارف انام مش
عارف من مره من الشتاء مش قادر اغمض
عيوني